digamos que tengo el siguiente número
pensemos
los estoy escribiendo con diferentes
colores para que los expandamos en unos
segundos punto decimal
fue un poco lento pero ya lo veremos y
lo que vamos a hacer es expandirlo por
su valor posicional digamos que este 9
se encuentra en la posición de las
centenas lo que representa realmente un
por 100 o 900
ese es el 9 y en las decenas tenemos un
0 10 que está multiplicándose por 10 así
es que será 0 y no nos estará añadiendo
valor a este número sin embargo tenemos
aquí un 5 en las unidades
tomaremos este 5 en el valor posicional
de las unidades lo cual representa un 5
por 1
este 5 que está siendo multiplicado por
unidades por una unidad lo cual
significa 5
en la parte de los decimales tenemos
este cero en las décimas tampoco lo
colocaremos no nos está añadiendo valor
nos vamos directo con las centésimas
este 7 está en el lugar de las
centésimas o lo que representa un 7 x
un centésimo
que es igual
7 centésimos
finalmente tenemos este 4 en el lugar de
los milésimos y lo que nos representa es
realmente un 4 por
milésima
o lo que es igual cuatro milésimos
con un color neutro pondré el valor
posicional de cada uno recuerda este 9
está en las centenas
centenas este cero se encuentra en la
posición de las decenas el 5 se
encuentra en las unidades
mientras que los decimales este 0 está
en los décimos
el 7 en los centésimos y el 4 en los
miles y 2
esto que hemos hecho realmente es para
que ustedes puedan entender el valor
posicional y lo que representa que cada
número se encuentre en una de estas
posiciones
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo